[Music]
how are you doing today sir how you
doing I'm doing excellent first of all
thank you so much for coming in yeah
before we get started I have to give a
huge thank you to the only reason we get
to be at the Toronto Film Festival is
because of our sponsors when you give a
huge thank you to Nordstrom Canada for
being an awesome sponsor and letting us
be here at this great space it's the
only reason we get to be here so a huge
thank you let's get started
so first of all I I feel like I've seen
you on a million things from last ship
designated survivor all the CW superhero
shows do you know where you are today I
do not and a million things is nice I
was thinking a thousand things right no
but I mean like you get up I'm going
unconscious right now like I was working
yesterday on erover stuff and I took a
flight got in this morning and yeah so
what are we in what is this Montreal no
rolana
exactly all right wait it is crazy
though and I want to get into clemency
which is the reason I get to talk to you
but of course I am a fan of the CW show
and I know based purely on the way
they've been building that your
character is clearly the linchpin of
crisis on Infinite Earths yeah I mean so
what is that I mean that has to be cool
for you bringing the monitor out was a
big deal he's you know he's not as big
as other characters that you would you
know you double you'd see like Superman
and Batman and all these other
characters he's kind of obscure but
bringing that to life for the first time
was fun and when they told me I was
gonna be the anti-monitor that was a
game changer I'm like so I get to play
both of them so that's I'm in heaven
right now like it's it's a good it's a
good experience well the other thing is
that like this is the final season of
arrow and just using like my brain I can
see that the ending of the series is
probably involving your character like
the very very end so I'm just gonna ask
you do you actually know that what is
all gonna happen at the very end of
everything and you're holding it I do
not I know the comic book you know I'm
sure they're sticking pretty close to
what the comic book was so that's kind
of it's a good thing but you can't adapt
everything from the page sure but
they're doing their spin on it and so
far it's it's like they're hitting it
out of the
work and also the one thing about that
show is that you've been on flash
Supergirl
legends and arrow yeah how is it
different or do those shows run very
similarly in terms of the production
schedule in terms of the way they
operate on set or is it sort of like is
or any of the shows a little different
than the others I do a lot with the the
makeup departments because of my whole
getup so there's different personalities
within those departments and you could
tell arrows been there for a while
they've been there for eight seasons so
they're just a well-oiled machine you
know I mean so they there's little
things that are different between all of
them but most of them run pretty tight
ship so it you know it's all good right
and I'm sorry for drilling down on this
but like how is it do a lot of times
with certain shows you'll be getting
pink purple yellow pages that before how
is it when you're playing this character
in terms of how much is it changing on
the fly and how much is it sort of like
pretty ironclad there's a lot of changes
that go on and it's with with that
character he he has the cadence the way
he speaks like I don't speak general
think anyone speaks like the monitor so
I kind of get I get the character down
and when there's changes on the last
minute it kind of throws off a little
bit but you just you know you
recalibrate you check back in and you
you know you go for it Jeff's been
hitting home since my last thing for you
on these shows where are you are you
allowed to say where you are in the
shooting schedule like what are you
shooting where you midway through midway
through an arrow I bounced around to you
know different shows we just wrapped
episode 5 of arrow
it's the halfway point got it and we
start shooting crisis maybe in another
month
yeah I'm gathering right now that you
are more of a part of arrow this season
than I realized
yeah I'm arrow heavy this year I was
gonna say well you also I think it ended
with you basically picking him up or
something and saying or something's
happening pretty much told him to get
his affairs in order exactly I remember
that yeah it's something's coming so
monitor and arrow are pretty much joined
at the hip for this last season but he
does bounce around and he wreaks havoc
you know and you think monitor is bad
it's like bad cop/worse cop because anti
monitors come in so you know the
audience that's hating one person right
now when they see the other guy it's
gonna it's gonna be real right well
first of all I'm just gonna say congrats
on booking an awesome gig like that
thank you very much I definitely want to
jump backwards a little bit and say so
you were on designated survivor last
ship what are what's like some memories
from making those shows that like you'll
always remember the last ship the first
day on they shoot different they like
block shoot everything and there's a lot
of dialogue and there's that dialogue
where it's that Navy jargon that you
just don't know like it's just the book
like you know doctor talk sure if you
don't know what you don't know it and
the first day I you know I knew what
scenes I thought we were shooting and
pretty much we ran through the whole the
whole episode the whole script like
we're gonna shoot all this one way and I
was like oh crap so I had to go and you
know I got through it and it turned out
great but it was like that was I'll
never forget that so from that point on
I over prepare for every no matter what
it is what the job I make sure that I'd
know everything that's going on so they
caught me off guard but it was it was
different
so you basically changed your entire
working habit as a result of last year
last year Yeah right I did that right
the other thing about that one though is
that show featured a hell of a lot of
action yeah you know what I mean and
you're trying to make that on a TV
production schedule so some of those
days you're shooting that action are you
like barely getting two takes or is it
you know what I mean there are certain
directors that shot more Peter Weller
was one that he got everything on one
take like it was you know and it's
knowing who's speaking when and the
cameras whipping around it was like one
long scene and his way of doing that he
left little room for the editors to go
in there and mess up his what he wanted
so you did one take this is what we're
using and everybody hit it out the park
so it worked
designated survivor what any memories
from that yeah there was a I wear a lot
of Jordans were a lot of Nikes you know
like rehearsing sure and
Keifer likes it quiet when we rehearse
the whole stage is quiet so I had airmax
on and you know when the bubbles pop
yeah and it's like you know a lot of
walking talks so we're walking through
the White House we're walking and
walking there's that noise and he's like
you know where's that noise coming from
and I stopped and I was like I don't
know I really didn't know it first and
then we kept walking we kept walking
walking togs like who who is it I think
it's me
but I'm not saying nothing right I keep
it to myself and we started walking
again he is that you yeah man yeah
that's uh that's so from that point on I
started wearing hard bottoms to uh to
rehearsals that's so funny that's
another story
are you a sneaker head I'm a sneaker
head Yeah right okay cuz I don't I am
NOT a sneaker head but I've learned the
culture recently yeah so what's the last
pair you had to buy on the drop on the
drop I just bought some threes Jordan
threes white cement how tough is it now
do you have a hookup now that you're an
actor I do not so you really someone out
there is watching right no no are you
using like an app or you like cuz I know
the city crap right yeah I know there's
a lot of apps that you need to like log
in at the right time and like get your
[ __ ] together yeah so you're doing that
too yeah okay wake up at 6:59 for real 7
o'clock boom did I get it nope art going
back to sleep that's the yeah okay and
so of course I have to ask what's the
most you've spent on a pair of kicks
five hundred bucks okay was it on the
aftermarket or was aftermarket yeah it
was just some like I really wanted them
sure what do you remember what they were
the oh jeez the ones and I couldn't find
him anywhere and the person I bought him
from just yeah he hiked it up I get it
someone's gonna pay I did know I've
heard that from a lot of people yeah are
you in New York or LA LA so I know that
there's stores in LA that sell on the
after market or go to any of those I
don't like doing the line thing yeah I
don't either
yeah if I don't get it I'd rather pay
more money sitting on my couch at 5:00
in the morning and waiting all day so
right now I have that mentality - yeah
right no you got to listen you got to
talk to someone because when you're in
front of the camera you'd like to think
someone's gonna hook you up it'd be nice
yeah and again if some
right so do you have a pair of what if
there's a fire you gotta hustle you [ __ ]
out of your place yeah what's the one
pair or two pairs you have to grab my oh
jeez and my black cements and I have
ones that aren't like they're not
popular they're not like the ones that
have to get but I just love them like I
just got some some yellow ones
taxi color and they're they're awesome
and they you know they match my watch
sure so little things you know you're
not the most expensive but I I wear them
although all over the place
jumping it's why I get to talk to you so
your TIFF is playing clemency which also
premiered at Sundance yeah talk a little
bit about what the film is about and who
you play the film is about death row and
the effects it has on everyone not just
the prisoner and the prisoners family
but the effects it has on the
administration the warden security
guards you know the administration I
play the head of all he's in charge of
all the guards also the executioner the
major for the prison and the toll it
takes on everyone so you know it's just
uh it's a dark movie but it's it's
topical and it's something that needs to
be talked about like wherever you stand
on capital punishment it'll give you a
different perspective of it completely
what is it you must have had scenes with
Alfred Yeah right what's it like working
with someone like her intense like alpha
is great but she's over prepared she
comes in she's the first one there she
just she's on top of it like she's she's
great to work with yeah I can't imagine
yeah and she's been doing it for so long
and I was watching her before I was
acting so it's like you know sharing the
screen where there was a big deal for me
sure what's like a what's a day from
filming that you will always remember
actually the funny part about that film
is I was working undesignated when I got
it
I went home over the break I had like
you know a few days off I went had an
audition for it and I got it but it kind
of overlapped with my shooting schedule
and i was shooting here in toronto for
designated so i told the producers like
i got this job I really want to do it I
read the script I know it's going to
a big deal I just I want to do it there
like I don't know clemency they were
like kind of weird because me flying
back and forth to do that what if I miss
my flight sure no wanted I get it so I
told them just rest easy I'll get it
designated made it work so there were
days where I would work out here take a
red-eye back home from the airport
straight to set to the trailer shoot all
day on clemency that night without even
going home to my LA house fly back to
Toronto go straight to the trailer shoot
all day and I was doing that for like
three or four straight days so in my
apartment in Toronto and my house in LA
I didn't see for four days it was just I
gotta tell you something I I have flown
a bunch for this job yeah and I don't
know how you pulled this one off because
are you can you sleep instantly on
planes
I can't am i right here this week for
this was was turbulent and I was trying
to sleep and it didn't didn't work out
for me but I slept in the trailer a
little bit you know when I was filming
and it you know coffee and just make it
happen
sure look it's a good gig yeah it's a
great and it's like you live for those
moments like talking about it now and
looking back at it like I had so much
fun during that four or five day span
that it was it's memorable now sure and
I told the producers like this film is
gonna be a big deal and it turned out we
won you know Grand Jury Prize at Sunday
no big deal you know so what's coming up
obviously you're booked on arrow and the
CW stuff and with crisis but I do you
think look what's coming up next or is
it I have a film I did with with Nick
Cage called primal can't go wrong with
Nick can't go wrong with Nick it's gonna
be here tomorrow actually Izzy in the
studio oh wow I got a I might sneak up
on him right he's coming in tomorrow
apparently he is filming something it
has a look going right now yeah and it's
always got a look though yeah yeah he's
always got something like Nick said he's
a really good dude the film famke
janssen Michael Imperioli
kevin durand like it's a fun old-school
action film Lionsgate is doing it and I
think we got a really it's going to be
VOD and
theatres November 8 I'm not sure oh sure
yeah it's coming up they do a lot of
that with Lionsgate movies it's like in
in theaters and on demand the same day
so that's gonna be a fun one when it
comes out and a couple of guest stars on
different shows can't talk about it yet
but when it pops up it'll be a
million-in-one shows that you Ray got it
my last thing for you have you borrowed
anything from the set of any of your CW
shows because I mean obviously you gonna
give it back
well I yeah obviously yeah I borrowed a
lot of comic books yesterday on set we
we did photos for my own action figure
shut up so I'm about to have a monitor
action figure so that was fun and when
that comes out imma borrow that too and
put it with the rest of my comic book
collection and action figures yeah I was
gonna say that's like dream come true
[ __ ] yeah um yeah yeah no it's awesome
yeah do you collect anything I do
what do you comic books Oh for real I'm
a comic book so you're losing your mind
doing this get absolutely lose right and
I told my manager like I do this for
free said don't repeat that don't tell
anybody
right right so totally in fact you
didn't tell me exactly so you're
basically paying to be on air oh yeah
pretty much
right it's a fun it's just being around
all the superhero like I talked and you
know I'm a big nerd but it's fun sure
you know you get to leave set at all
wearing the costume or is it like super
ironclad that you can't I can't leave
set with a costume but my mutton chops
in the hair I had like a six hour break
in between shots once so I went back to
the hotel and the looks I got like
people just got out of the way like I
could have robbed a bank in broad
daylight with that hair and the mutton
chops and it you know because for me
like that's like I had like that the gig
that you have I would immediately go to
the supermarket or Starbucks and just
walk around just just get those reaction
I tried we worked last Halloween and I
got off like at 11:00 and I begged like
please let me walk Granville Street like
just with this whole getup on sure no
dice but the thing is sometimes with era
when the other shows are filming on the
streets yeah they're on location so I
was like it's just three blocks kicks I
can walk up the street I'll bring it
back right like no no yeah it's so funny
I think you know I'm not feeling good
just let me I gotta go for a quick walk
yeah right I tried it all didn't take
great I get it yeah hey listen I got to
stop there I'm just going to say
Congrats on everything that's happening
for with you I cannot wait to see how
arrows gonna wrap up in crisis because
each of these you know group groups I
forget what the right terms are the
crossovers yeah the crossover have been
getting better and better yeah
and this is obviously he's gonna be the
grandfather of all Crosse exactly can't
wait for you guys to see what we've been
working on completely awesome thank you
so much for coming in thanks brother
appreciate it